family split apart harry meghan and the
royals
there's no secret that william and harry
have had some differences but
today is archie's second birthday i'm
told there probably will be a video call
so that there is an opportunity
for archie to be his cousin harry and
megan posted this new
filtered birthday photo of archie from
behind holding balloons
the queen prince charles and the duke
and duchess of cambridge
also posted happy birthday messages on
instagram
i think prince harry's attendance at the
duke of edible funeral was the thawing
of the ice and i think
was the beginning of healing this rift
and rebuilding bridges
megan may have received a reported 700
thousand dollar advance for her new
children's book the bench
meanwhile william and kate seem to be in
the midst of a major image overhaul
the latest piece a new youtube channel
be careful what you say now because
these guys they're filming i know
i think we are seeing them rebranding to
a degree
that charming but very carefully
choreographed
video to celebrate their 10th wedding
anniversary i think
they are tapping into that to make
themselves more real
more relatable if that is the strategy
it's certainly working because the
cambridge's popularity
is really soaring